now I said she should compete she should  try to win right okay I'm not saying  it's good odds I'm not even saying I'd  recommend it I'm just saying like I I  can't fault someone if you're if you're  and I'm not saying I don't know the his  girlfriend's situation whatever but it's  like I know the numbers behind it and I  know there's a lot of men in marriages  that they can't get out because she can  leave and take half your [ __ ] and she so  and she can take your kids with you and  then on top of that like he's basically  chained in because one out of four  marriages are sexless so she cannot  sleep with him and then he doesn't want  to get a divorce because she's going to  take half the [ __ ] so it's like if he's  in there's a lot of men that are in  those situations and it's and it's like  if one out of four men are in those  situations and another girl comes in and  sees this like I just I gotta respect  the game that's all I say game